bonjour et bienvenue sur scène son rôle
aujourd'hui vous fait la première vidéo
d'une nouvelle série de vidéos s'appelle
my force m
je vais me permettre de donner mon avis
personnel sur des questions puis je juge
importante de sucre et non pas les
sciences et les mathématiques en tant
que tel mais plus sur la manière dont on
parle des sciences et des mathématiques
notamment si je fais ça c'est pas mal en
réaction à des supers commentaires que
j'ai reçu sur ma vidéo numéro 15 dont
j'ai parlé dans les commentaires de la
vidéo 16 donc cela avait à voir avec
l'erreur que les erreurs que l'on peut
faire dans des vidéos de vulgarisation
scientifique notamment
alors je veux pas commencer avec un truc
aussi totti pour l'après vidéo de my
phone 7 on va faire un truc un peu plus
léger et puis la prochaine vidéo ça
parlera des erreurs donc aujourd'hui
j'ai envie de vous parler de la
terminologie de vulgarisation
scientifique
il ya quelques semaines j'avais la
chance d'être à al ain aux castes
c'était super cool en tout cas pour
vidéo science eu d'autres problèmes dont
je veux pas rentrer dedans et à l'année
aux castes on a fait une table ronde sur
la vulgarisation scientifique sur le web
où il y avait notamment fred courant de
fred et jamy de c'est pas sorcier de
l'esprit sorcier maintenant sur le web
et cette table ronde était présidée par
pierre kerner de la chaîne string funk
swing ce qui est aussi le créateur de
ville aux sciences bref pierre pour sa
première question de la table ronde nous
a demandé si on émet la terminologie
vulgarisation scientifique
donc là la majorité des gens ont levé la
main mais moi et d'autres n'a pas levé
la main sans doute parce qu'on est plus
de podcasts science et que sur peau de
questions c'est un mec qui s'appelle à
alan qui a répété plusieurs fois son
mécontentement de par rapport à la
terminologie vulgarisation scientifique
qui donne un air top down et
condescendant alors comme je n'avais pas
levé les mains que j'étais juste à côté
de pierre pierre m'a donné le micro je
me suis retrouvé à côté de fred à lui
expliquer pourquoi il s'était trompé sur
la première question
autant dire c'était pas une classe et
une situation très confortable surtout
que je l'expliquais que je trouvais que
le concept de vulgarisation j'explique à
tout concept de vulgarisation revient en
r top down condescendant a répété un peu
les mots d'alan vous faites du sagou été
deux fois deux courants de faire un
petit peu une leçon sur la descendance
foot et bernard pas bien j'étais
vraiment à l'aise
merci pierre de m'avoir mis dans cette
situation donc ça peut paraître
anecdotique
pourtant chance qu'on ait fait ça révèle
un quelque chose en tout cas sur la
manière dont on communique les sciences
et je pense que concept de vulgarisation
scientifique décrit très très très mal
en tout cas niveau intuitif feeling ce
que j'essaie de faire sur scène ce forum
est ce que je pense qu'il faut faire
quand on cherche à promouvoir les
sciences et les mathématiques
alors le bien sûr j'utilise quand même
beaucoup le mot vulgarisation
scientifique notamment bas parce que
c'est ce que les gens comprennent ce que
les gens connaissent
du coup utiliser d'autres mots pour dire
ce que je fais ça c'est soulève plus de
questions qu autre chose et des
questions qui ne sont pas forcément les
plus importantes je dirais mais qui sont
quand même importante donc je vais en
parler
une des alternatives que câline propose
sur podcast science c'est de parler
plutôt que de vulgarisation scientifique
de médiation de communications
scientifiques se sont déterminés toudji
que j'utilise je crois que sur mon
compte twitter il doit y avoir avec le
médiateur scientifique mais c'est pas
des terminologies que j'affectionne plus
que ça peut-être que j'ai une mauvaise
connotation
des concepts même de médiaterre de
communicateur je pense que ce qu'il me
dérange peut-être le plus dense là c'est
ça donne l'impression que je vais vous
raconter ce que disent les chercheurs
c'est pas du tout le cas parce que je
vois raconte c'est plutôt ce qu'on dit
les chercheurs du paseo bien tu as assez
rien à voir avec l'actualité ou quelque
chose qu'il faudrait que les chercheurs
disait qu'il faudrait un communiqué non
je pense que c'est pas vraiment ce que
je fais c'est pour ça que je suis un peu
gêné mois par le procès de médiateurs de
communicateur scientifique
en tout cas je pense que c'est pas
recette optimale je pense qu'il a des
sous-entendus qui sont pas les bons une
autre notre proposition celle utilisé le
terme anglais qui est largement mieux à
mon goût qui est le terme de
popularisation le populaire les acteurs
scientifiques et en effet l'aca se
rapprochent déjà beaucoup plus de ce que
j'essaie de faire en tout cas sur cinq
soit roll je suis je cherche davantage à
rendre les mathématiques et les sciences
populaire car les communiqués on va dire
clairement un de mes grands objectifs
soit cesser de faire aimer les
mathématiques et les sciences de les
rendre populaire de faire en sorte que
vous en parliez
a déjeuné avec vos collègues ou le soir
entre famille ou avec des amis autour
d'une bière ça c'est mon rêve cas c'est
ce que j'essaie de faire et du coup ce
que j'essaie de faire c'est plus de la
popularisation des sources issues des
sciences et des mathématiques qu'une
communication une médiation des
mathématiques et des sciences
je préfère largement le terme de
popularisation mais s'il faut changer
moi j'ai une proposition encore en
meilleur selon moi que popularisa teurs
scientifique c'est un petit peu long à
dire un petit peu chiant impunis gens
justement ce que c'est le terme que je
proposerai moi c'est guide scientifique
ou guy mathématiques qui se lèverait
peut-être encore plus de questions mais
je pense que ça décrit encore mieux ce
que je fais une superbe vidéo de robots
jamais sur podcast science et sur ceux
là où il raconte l'utilisa métaphore de
l'alpinisme pour décrire non seulement
les mathématiques qui sont un paysage du
coup dans cette métaphore mais aussi se
le font les chercheurs en mathématiques
c'est résister de de tracer des routes
et le métier de robin en particulier le
travail au palais de la découverte en
tant que scientifique je me dis de
mathématiques qui consiste à essayer
d'amener les gens sur les routes tracées
par par d'autres voire aller à donner
les outils pour que ces gens là puisse
tracer leur propre route
et moi j'adore cette analogie mme
surtout que sur mon temps libre
j'adore voyager je fais un grand
voyageur ambac thacker 1010 est anglais
je veux bien voyager seul et explorer
des territoires hors des sentiers battus
et je vois mon aventure mathématiques de
façon très similaire
je pense que pour bien vivre respirer
profitez des mathématiques faire des
belles mathématiques il faut avoir un
espèce d'élan aventuriers vouloir aller
partir à l'exploration et chercher à
comprendre le monde
autour de soi ceci le paysage en
mathématiques en l'occurrence et
difficile d'accès il faut il faut il
faut des délais des exemples technique
pour se balader sur ce long de ce
paysage et sont difficiles à acquérir
par soi même
du coup si vous voulez un jour vous
attaquer à des très hautes montagnes
même juste pouvoir vous balader
tranquillement de vous même dans ce
paysage en mathématiques
le mieux est encore de d'utiliser un
guide mathématiques au moins à des
endroits où vous êtes un peu perdu
vous savez pas trop comment bien
naviguer le long du terrain et c'est là
que j'interviens où j'espère intervenir
non seulement pour vous dire comment
vous aider un petit peu vous aiguiller
un petit peu dans le votre exploration
mathématiques mais mais aussi et surtout
pour vous donner envie de faire l'effort
d'aller vous baladez vous de vous même
dans cet espace mathématiques de donner
envie de délai gambader et donc mon vrai
objectif moins six que vous ayez envie
de vous balader dans votre propre
paysage mathématiques de l'état et
partir à l'exploration et quand je lis
certains des commentaires que j'ai qui
vous vous proposez de vos propres
expériences de pensée
vous proposez vos propre raisonnement
vous posez vos propres questions
beh me sens heureux parce que c'est
exactement enfin ça super plaisir c'est
exactement ce que je veux et donc pour
revenir à au fil de discussion avec
oxylane east et ses discussions sur les
référentiels donc que je n'ai pas
mentionné dans la vidéo 15 au final on a
eu une discussion absolument génial
on a progressé je pense tous les deux
dans notre papa notre compréhension des
lois de newton puisqu'on lui sont dues
connaissez assez bien nous deux plus
deux mais sur la manière dont on
réfléchit dont on parle de ces lois de
newton et peut-être de la manière donc
il faut les enseigner également
bref tout ça pour dire que ce que
j'essaie vraiment de vous faire c'est de
vous emmener dans une aventure
j'espère que vous avez senti un petit
peu ça dans mes vidéos
j'aimerais que à chaque fois que vous
regardez une vidéo vous vous sentiez
transporté dans un autre univers un peu
platonicien où les choses ne sont pas
comme dans votre quotidien
et puis vous avez l'impression de de
voyager et de voir des choses qui
suscite votre curiosité et qui vous
donne envie de continuer à voyager de
vous même même une fois que la vidéo est
terminée ça c'est vraiment un objectif
et je pense qu'au final si le succès de
2 2 c'est pas sorcier pour en revenir à
fred sessa vient de cela aussi encore en
début de chaque épisode quand ils sont
dans le camion et qui font de
l'introduction et ils disent à marcel de
chauffer les moteurs
c'est cette impression coeur on part en
voyage avec fred et jamy et finalement
fred et jamy sont tout autant associés
pour moi une idée de voyage de parcours
de découverte
peut-être même plus qui a une idée de
fait d'une collection de fait réciter
pour moi une vidéo qui ne fais que citer
une liste de faits et qui donne pas
l'impression de nous emmener dans un
voyage c'est une mauvaise vidéo de de
sciences cloud de voyage scientifique et
c'est pour ça aussi que j'ai fait cette
vidéo dans la voiture si je pense que
c'est pas du tout la meilleure loin de
là en termes d'explication
elle propose quand même une idée de
voyage qui est extrêmement plaisante en
fait des dans une voiture ça donne
l'impression que bon on se balade on se
balade dans un univers mathématiques et
c'est pour ça que je pense que cette
vidéo même si elle n'explique pas bien
pas mal de choses
elle elle permet tout de même
d'atteindre mon objectif qui est de vous
emmener dans un voyage de vous sortir de
votre quotidien et de vous faire
réfléchir au monde qui est autour de
vous j'espère que vous avez apprécié
cette petite discussion c'était my
forcément ça vaut ce que ça vaut mais
vous avez donc les avis comptent au
moins autant que le mien vous invite à
laisser vos avis dans les commentaires
quelle est votre vision de la foi de ce
qui se fait aujourd'hui en vulgarisation
stage communication slash médiation au
plus récent stage voyage mathématiques
et de ce que vous voudriez que ceux ci
soient quelles sont les choses qui me
font vraiment plaisir dans ces voyages
que cette aventure que nous partageons
ensemble